-Et de nouveau, à cause d'un nom,
un nom sur un visage,
..un visage sur un corps, Cannes
a été la proie d'un tourbillon.
Pas tout de suite,
à l'aérodrome de Nice,
..elle n'était guère connue.
Mais dès que l'on a su d'avantage,
..cela a changé.
Claudia Cardinale,
..c'est ce qu'on peut voir de plus
jolie en ce moment sur la croisette,
..de plus vivant,
de plus heureux de vivre...
Jugez-en plutôt.
...
Et contrairement à ce que
vous pourriez supposer,
..toutes ces images
sont douées de la parole.
Il semble que le cinéma
soit fixé une fois pour toute.
Les grandes vedettes sont de
grandes vedettes depuis longtemps,
..voir même des fois avant-guerre.
Quant aux nouvelles,
..à peine apprend-t-on leurs noms
qu'elles deviennent célèbres,
..et à peine sont-elles célèbres
qu'on oublie leurs noms.
Heureusement,
vous voilà Claudia Cardinale,
..vous êtes jeune,
votre carrière est assurée.
En outre, vous nous faites un cadeau
inestimable, vous parlez français.
-Oui. Je suis née à Tunis,
et j'ai fais mes études en français.
A la maison je parle français,
mais je suis Italienne.
-Il n'y a pas très longtemps
que vous êtes en Italie.
-Non, ça fait exactement 3 ans
quand j'ai débuté avec "Le Pigeon".
-Vous êtes venue en Italie...
Comment est-ce que
vous avez tourné "Le Pigeon" ?
-C'était compliqué car je n'avais
pas envie de faire du cinéma.
C'était bien malgré moi,
mais je suis contente.
-Pourquoi vous n'y avez pas envie ?
-Je n'y pensais pas, j'allais
en classe. Une vie bien différente.
-Vous avez fait
un concours de beauté.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
-Ca donne quand même
envie de faire du cinéma ?
-Non, c'était pour le voyage,
le festival de Venise.
-C'est curieux, chez nous les
concours de beauté ça sert à rien,
..seulement en Italie.
On ne sait pas pourquoi.
Les Italiennes recevant
les prix de beauté font du cinéma.
Chez nous,
c'est exactement le contraire.
-Heureusement pour moi.
-Depuis, vous avez fait
de nombreux films, dont "Le Pigeon".
Vous avez fait combien de films ?
-En tout, 14.
-14, en 3 ans ?
-Oui.
-Et ici, vous arrivez à Cannes
avec 2 films.
Vous devez représenter presque
tout le cinéma italien à Cannes.
-Double peur !
-Quels sont ces films ?
-Le premier qui sera présenté
ce soir, "La Viaccia", de Bolognini,
..avec Jean-Paul Belmondo.
-Que veut dire "la viaccia" ?
-"Le mauvais chemin".
Et le 2e,
"La Fille à la valise", de Zurlini,
..avec Perrin.
-Vous êtes encore très jeune,
..mais le fait même que vous avez
fait autant de films prouve..
..que vous devez avoir des idées
sur la façon de mener votre vie.
Comment entendez-vous
conduire votre carrière ?
-Surtout ne pas suivre une route.
Par exemple, être dramatique ou être
comique, mais j'aime faire tout.
-On dirait d'ailleurs que vous
avez peur de devenir un personnage.
Vos images dans les livres
sont toutes différentes.
-Je préfère.
-Votre personnage vous déplaît ?
-Non, ce n'est pas ça,
..c'est parce que j'aime faire tout,
c'est plus intéressant.
-Vous trouvez normal le succès
que peut avoir une actrice ?
-Ca, je ne sais pas.
Je suis toujours très étonnée.
Je ne sais pas.
-Quand vous pensez
aux grands savants,
..est-ce normal qu'on demande
des autographes..
..aux gens qui font du cinéma ?
-Peut-être.
Mais c'est une chose
tellement incroyable..
..d'être connu comme ça
par le cinéma.
Savant, mais c'est comme ça.
-Si le cinéma vous oubliait,
ça vous ferez de la peine ?
-Comment ?
-Si on vous oubliais demain ?
-Bien sûr,
ça me ferait de la peine.
Mais je ferait autre chose.
Je regretterais, naturellement.
-Que feriez-vous ?
-Il y a beaucoup de choses.
J'aimerais, par exemple,
m'occuper de mode.
Ou voyager, ne rien faire.
-Est-ce qu'il vous arrive de suivre
les conseils qu'on vous donne ?
-Oui. Oui, j'écoute, mais
j'en fais un peu à ma tête.
-Est-ce que vous suivriez
le conseil que je vais vous donner ?
-Lequel ?
-Restez toujours comme vous êtes.
-Merci.